the scale of the looming economic crisis
is hard to fathom in Europe like in much
of the rest of the world empty streets
and shuttered shops show just how
suddenly and dramatically business has
ground to a standstill national
governments in the nineteen member
eurozone have been introducing stimulus
packages aimed at keeping businesses and
their employees afloat now another
question has arisen how to pay for it
all at present each country in the
eurozone is responsible for its own debt
this means that a country with a poor
credit rating like Italy has to pay a
higher interest rate than a lesson
detonation like Germany the idea behind
the so-called corona bonds is to pool
debt instead this would ease borrowing
costs for a country like Italy but
increase the burden for more
creditworthy nations like germany the
idea has predictably led to internal
wrangling in the eurozone with Italy
France and Spain in favour of the plan
and Germany and the Netherlands against
and even if there were a consensus
experts say implementing such a scheme
could take months or even years back in
the Chancellery after two weeks in
quarantine and three- coronavirus tests
German Chancellor Angela Merkel made her
return in my opinion Europe the European
Union is facing its biggest test since
its foundation our populations are also
facing a huge health challenge all the
EU member states are being affected on
varying levels we're all affected and so
it must be in everyone's interest and it
is in Germany's interest that Europe
should emerge strongly from this test
over forged as Merkel voiced her
concerns for Europe on Monday her
government's crisis group agreed to
institute a two-week quarantine for
people returning to Germany from April
10th all German nationals EU citizens
and other longtime residents who
returned
after several days abroad we'll have to
quarantine themselves for 14 days
there are however exceptions including
seasonal workers in agriculture
commuters traveling to work truck
drivers delivering goods and of course
medical professionals Germany also
announced on Monday the latest extension
to its 1.1 trillion euro coronavirus
crisis package a guarantee of 100% loans
to small and medium sized businesses of
up to eight hundred thousand euros these
middle stand companies are widely seen
as the heart of the German economy
anyone who is economically active last
year those who registered turnover those
who recorded normal economic activity
and made a profit they can get three
months turnover as a loan from the bank
which in this case will be 100%
financially underwritten by us
that means the banks will not have to do
normal financial risk assessments this
100% guarantee means the process will be
completed very quickly now Germany's
European neighbors too are looking to
Berlin to see whether Merkel's concerns
might also turn into financial support
for them
and here's DW correspondent Baird auriga
at explaining exactly the kind of
financial support Germany's European
neighbors are looking for 9 European
countries among them Italy France and
Spain are demanding common debt euro
bonds or corona bonds but Germany and
Austria and other wealthy countries say
we cannot afford this to finance common
euro bonds or common debt because we
don't know how we will come out of this
unprecedented crisis but many experts
and economists Ian Brussels say the 500
billion euros now on the table are not
enough you have to do more come up with
more money and Italy is asking quite
bluntly what is the EU for the
they cannot help us now DW political
correspondent Hans Brandt joins me now
from our parliamentary studios Hans what
is the EU for if it cannot help us now
that's the cry from some countries
angular Merkel acknowledges this is the
biggest test the EU has ever faced so
how much pressure is there on Germany to
contribute more money yes the pressure
on Germany is huge also within the
German political spectrum there are many
political parties and politicians here
in Germany that are pushing the
government urging the government to
agree to these corona bonds as they are
called but we have to caution that it's
not a matter of Germany giving money we
are talking here about loans that are to
be issued and about Germany and other
countries all countries in the European
Union guaranteeing those learn says not
actually money that's being kind of
pushed across the table it's a guarantee
for loans but because the German economy
is by far the strongest in Europe if
these loans should end up not being
repaid or in some sense getting
difficult it will be Germany that ends
up in some sense guaranteeing these
loans together with other countries so
it's that guarantee that the Germans are
concerned about the German Foreign
Minister and the economics minister have
recently published opinion pieces in the
series of European newspapers offering
their alternative they are saying that a
common European Stability Mechanism
which is already in place should be used
and that the rules for giving that money
to various countries should be relaxed
so Germany is hoping in some things to
get out of this bind and still be able
to help other countries
speaking of relaxations the Chancellor
also said it's too early to set a date
for the relaxation of social distancing
why is Germany not following Austria
into issuing a timed programme of dates
for restrictions to be lifted well both
Chancellor Merkel and members of her
cabinet for instance the economics
minister only this morning have been
stressing that it's much too early for
Germany even to talk about a date when
this might happen when the relaxation
might happen they are emphasizing that
the restrictions will remain in place at
until the 19th of April in other words
ten days or so and only when that date
approaches will they start talking about
possible relaxations it has to do with
the fact that there is a feeling that
the situation in Germany is not under
control completely yet and also with the
fact that this is holiday times here in
Europe in Germany especially there's the
Easter weekend coming up and one wants
to discourage people from leaving their
home from relaxing their guard from
letting down their guard from meeting
other people and so on so in this under
these circumstances the feeling is that
things have to remain under control and
strictly controlled hands broad speaking
to us from our parliamentary studios
thank you very much
let's get you the latest developments
related to the global la coruna virus
pandemic China has reported no new
deaths from the corona virus over the
past 24 hours and the 32 new cases the
country did report were people who
returned from overseas Israel has
announced a complete lockdown over the
upcoming Passover holiday here in
Germany the number of confirmed
coronavirus infections has passed a
hundred thousand the fourth highest
caseload in the world and Japan has
declared a state of emergency in Tokyo
and six other regions to combat the
outbreak Japan has nearly 4,000
confirmed cases of kovat 19 and 92
deaths from it for more I'm joined by
journalist Sonia Blaschka in Tokyo Sonia
what does a state of emergency mean in
concrete terms it means that the
governors have the authority to call on
people to stay home and for businesses
to close however they don't have they
cannot give any penalties and it's not
like a european-style lockdown so to
speak so people are still free to move
it's still basically more or less a very
strong appeal and if you compare it to
Europe the the situation here is very
different
much less restricted it's it's much more
like regular life and I'm hoping that
with the state of emergency this sense
of crisis so to speak will will change
and it affects the two main regions in
Japan it affects Tokyo and the greater
Tokyo area with 35 million people and
also the greater osaka and kyoto area
before for well over a month right sonya
japan initially seemed to be on top of
the coronavirus response but infections
have surged recently what went wrong I
think in the beginning what helped was
the proximity to China
there was a very early in the crisis a
sense that that people really need to
take care be careful and all that
schools were closed relatively early but
I think because it kind of took so long
and the the number of infections stay
relatively low people maybe forgot about
a little bit or starts to get a little
complacent and then the cherry blossom
season happened we had a super nice
weekend in in March a lot of people went
through the parks despite pleas not to
do so and I think the results is what
we're seeing now and Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a has also announced a huge
stimulus package what can you tell us
about that yes he has announced a
stimulus package which amounts to 108
trillion yen which is 916 billion euros
and it's equivalent to 20 percent of the
Japanese economic output compared to
Germany Germany has invested around five
percent the the goal is obviously to
prevent recession from happening and
maybe just turn it into some sort of a
depression they will give money to
families whose income has dropped by
over 50% they will give them three
hundred thousand yen that's about more
than four hundred euros and also maybe
around 80 euros per child then also
money for companies 2 million yen so
that's what the stimulus package model
is in place
Sonia Blaschka in Tokyo thank you very
much for that you're welcome